they're waiting for John Stipe but the  fight that they want most of all  is this so John Stipe is their second  choice  their first choice is John Francis  and they're hoping Francis re-signs and  is able to go to fight in like January  February they would rather John go  straight to Francis than John go through  Stipe they want John Francis that's the  number one fight UFC wants to make  the caveat there is Francis the contract  the re-signing and then also his injury  yeah if they can resign Francis come to  agreement then you have John fight in  probably January February March at the  latest against Francis if Francis can't  get that deal done as a hold up or who  knows then they're trying to get John  Stipe on the December 10th card  if they can't get any of that done  you're getting Gary Glover in December